- How would I describe this?
- Great.
(rock music)
- For those of you who don't know,
Taiwan does not play
when it comes to food.
So, I thought it would be fun
to invite some of my friends
who've never had it before
and see what they think of it.
- I don't think I've
ever had Taiwanese food.
- I've had Chinese food.
- I've probably had it
once without knowing it.
- [Man In Plaid] Heysong Sarsaparilla.
- Oh.
- What.
- This is root beer.
- I want to put ice cream in it.
- It's like bubble gum.
- Bubble gum, some apple juice.
- Bubble gum?
- Bubble gum soda?
- Yeah, a little bit like a cream soda?
- [Girl In Gray] Yeah.
- A little, like it's very, very sweet.
- [Both Girls] Oooooh.
- This looks like Korean pancakes.
- It's very buttery.
- There's oil in between
every layer of this.
- Yeah.
- I would dip it in sauce.
- Yeah, there's like flaky layers.
- I feel uncomfortable
watching you peel it open.
- Why?
- I'm diggin' it.
It reminds me a lot of latkas.
- Every culture has
something like a tortilla.
- This definitely tastes
asian as f&@# though.
(laughing)
- [Girl In Gray] Is that garlic?
- Is it just straight up cloves of garlic?
- It doesn't have like the spice taste
that a lot of sausages have.
- Huh?
- [Girl In Gray] You don't like it?
- No, no it's not that I don't like it,
I just haven't tasted this before.
- It's kind of sweet.
- But it's like a good sweet.
- I don't get it, because
sausage is ground up.
But this doesn't look ground
up, it looks like it was ham.
- I love the garlic with it.
- I'm not mad at this.
- The garlic is strong.
- I love garlic, but it's a
decision to eat straight garlic.
- Yeah, I'll eat that.
- Oh my god, noodles.
- It smells so good.
- Is this bok choy?
- Funny because when I
eat that kind of food,
I never eat the cabbage.
- Why don't you eat the
cabbage? YB, it's great!
- I really like this.
- Refreshing and nature-y.
- This is definitely like a
lighter dish you would have.
- It's not too salty,
and it's not too sweet.
- It's good, you know,
it's beef noodle soup.
- The thing with pho, is that
the beef gets overcooked.
- Yeah I gotta take you
to better places then.
- Oh, egg.
- Oh my gosh.
- This is like Bulgogi.
- Yeah, I was about to say,
this looks kinda like Bulgogi.
- Taiwanese food is really
similar to Korean food.
- Oh my gosh.
(laughing)
- I love dishes that have
multiple animals in them.
- It almost melts in your
mouth 'cause it's just so soft.
- As a kid, I always ate rice
and I always hated eating rice
'cause then I'd always have
to like mix it with the meat
and stuff like this,
but this is like drenched
in like it's own sauce.
- Yas, all the way.
- There weren't like a million
ingredients in each thing,
there were like three to five
ingredients in every dish,
but they work very well together.
- Just like a few ingredients,
all happily chillin'
together in your mouth.
- A plus plus.
Get you some Taiwanese food
or get you someone who
knows how to make authentic
Taiwanese food.
- You can't have bland pork, you crazy?
- Is it just going to be an ad for pork?
- Yeah!
- Eat pork!
- Yeah, yeah, I think that's
- [Cameraman] Brought to you by pork.
- Brought to you by pork.